why you always got on Mitch Mitch sucks
why your siblings got mint mesh daddies
see someone's getting older so speaking
of relationships there's your little
boyfriend's to look at one there's your
boyfriend so go buy em eight two four
six four Lord we just wanna thank you
beautiful Thanksgiving with my big Amen
and God I thank you for with my cheating
let see Rand Paul could you pass the
rolls please maybe I like your fifth
Lane and they're like your fifth baby
daddy I've already had enough of this
I'm a little sick oil or grandpa comfort
me this time I see you still eating this
used to having found the right dentures
[Music]
what what you know that tattoos are a
lifetime commitment
but apparently either wear your first
and second wife funny sorry you're
funny-looking a little boyfriend on
Facebook
once the last time you saw your
funny-looking kids oh I mean what's
really not you know that's really a good
day today
you know when you gonna learn how to
cook baby we don't know how to stop
cheating on your husband you know what
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute let's put the brakes on right now
you know what they've been disrespectful
they have you should've heard what Ryan
said to me oh I thought what you think
they they grow never to grow well let's
remember that when they call and ask for
money
uh-huh ain't gonna get no money from
grass you wouldn't be driving that car